how did it feel to have Milo yonopolis
make Richard Spencer seem reasonable
you know perhaps to Richard Spencer for
either hiding his horrible ideology or
doing genuine Reformation I'm not sure
what she's doing you know I take people
I meet people where they're at
um Milo is I I feel like I understand
Milo pretty well maybe what is he who is
he no
um man my chat made fun of me when I
says but I feel like Milo I want to say
Milo for a brief moment in time was like
one of the top three to five most
popular political punny people in the
world in like 2016 right or in that era
he was going to colleges he had books
out he was everybody knew him all over
the world he was making everybody mad he
was on this like alt-right slash Trump
binge and then man that pedo convo
really just did a number on him he just
yeah the beginning of the Spiral down
did you see the Vlog where he
flew to Hawaii to try and throw his
engagement ring into an active volcano
and then the Hawaii local environmental
organization said we don't let people go
and throw personal possessions into
active volcanoes so he got a bottle of
vodka got on a rented a boat and then
was drinking the bottle of vodka showing
how expensive the ring was on his phone
before he blink just threw it into the
Pacific I did not see that that was a
sad sad Vlog yeah to watch cheers so
where is he now who is he now
um I think he's just desperately trying
to carve out some political Niche
um and and right now it seems like
that's like this Christian nationalist
thing but he like exists solely in these
strange spaces on telegram
um he has no like social media anywhere
because he's banned from everything and
he doesn't really have like a coherent
political ideology or lifestyle or
platform or anything so he's just like
yeah he's like grifted into this very
very Niche weird world where he's trying
to like make some kind of name for
himself but it doesn't seem like it's
going too well it seems to me watching
him against you and then also I've seen
him do a couple of other little
interviews over the last couple of years
it's kind of like watching a punch drunk
boxer trying to get back into the ring
one last time all of the
he did have kind of charm it was a real
trolley charm but there was something
like Whimsical and and kind of funny and
sort of subversive about what he used to
do
and then it was so just like icky and
gloves off but not in a ruthless way
kind of in a like a scrappy scrabbling
bottom of the barrel way with that
debate with you and then you bring up
like one point there's one bit of
pushback that you get like one
legitimate piece of pushback which was
still couched quite a lot for the people
that haven't seen it you brought up the
thing that he was canceled for as he
started accusing you of like having kids
that were going to be future pedophiles
yeah it's nothing you know like this is
not the stands for you of all people to
take and then that immediately just
broke his brain and I thought dude like
if you're gonna [__] dish it out for
50 minutes at least be able to take it
on the other side and he couldn't so it
really just I don't know it's like the
the death throws of some [__] like
old singer who's touring again and
doesn't can't hit the high notes yeah
that's basically how I view it now
what has changed then with the landscape
that means that Milo is no longer like
is it just that that kind of trolley
alt-right stuff is not called anymore
yeah so something um I give myself a lot
of credit for is I've been doing online
content now in a fairly relevant way for
about 13 years and in order to maintain
at a level to where you're still
accruing new followers where people
still want to look at you for what's
going on the modern day you're going to
have to adapt to the changing kind of
like political Landscapes
um I'm sure stuff changed fast in the
past too but man today on the internet
political movements will come and go in
like one to four years depending on the
movement Milo definitely thrived in this
kind of like alt-right explosive era
where trolling and attacking college
kids and being as provocative as
possible and pushing back against the
sjws you know that's what we used to
call woke people back in the 2016 days
that was like the height of what he did
but I feel like he never really adapted
past that and he's still kind of like
looking back towards that you know like
you so like he's got like his
provocative attitude and all of that and
he's got his you know I think men are
speaking copied from like Hitchens uh
where he's like you know there's trying
this oration style but he doesn't really
have any substance anymore like no
offense but like are we really looking
to like Milo yiannopoulos for the ideal
Christian type of lifestyle and now he's
like super pro censorship and it's like
yeah I don't know it's just very strange
you know I did a debate in Qatar about
masculinity about six weeks ago and they
put up a montage of a bunch of different
people commenting on how feminism had
gone too far the [__] first person
was Milo yiannopoulos I had to kind of
couch it I was like look I'd do it then
after that was Rogan and then there was
Peterson and blah blah blah
guys if if you have brought me here to
try and defend Milo yiannopoulos I'm
like that's not the job that I was sent
here to do like there's criticisms that
we can have about all sorts of stuff
like don't I'm not gonna jump on that
bandwagon uh another thing that's
interesting is how are you talking about
how quick political movements come and
go like Milo and Nick Fuentes I mean
that was the shortest relationship in
history
yeah I'm gonna be honest I called all of
that I told these [__] that
when the EA stuff popped up that this is
going to be like a two to three month
thing and it felt like Fuentes banked a
lot on yay being like his new explosive
reach to the public and I think Milo
also was like looking at like his way
back into Fame but yeah he's done this
before right where he wanted to run for
president I think in 2016 and he came
and went in like two weeks and then he
repeated like the same thing again I was
like how are you taking this guy
seriously the I love Hitler guy who has
no foundation for any political belief
whatsoever
um yeah that it was a short relationship
it was dumb I don't know how much you
follow on telegram no not much these
guys are fighting like crazy like I
think Fuentes just dropped yesterday
that this guy called Ali Alexander who
was the leader of the stop the steel
movement
is like a pedophile or something and
that Milo yiannopoulos was defending him
and I think Milo yiannopoulos a few days
ago is trying to drop things proving
that people are like they're all it's so
much crazy yeah but that's always like
the go-to I think with everybody yeah do
you do you know the word nonce do you
know what that is doesn't mean like
stupid in British or something Nancy is
pedo oh I didn't know that okay yeah so
you'll see if it's ever anybody in
England that's accusing someone else of
being a Peter would be that wasn't there
something didn't Nick Fuentes say that
Milo is taking Percocet to stop himself
from being gay isn't he medicating
himself out of his homosexuality that's
what he says so my when I'm writing
stuff on this on people I like sources I
don't need screenshots I need videos
these guys are making a lot of claims to
show that was any proof of anything so
it's really funny like I'll probably
repeat some of it if I'm trying to like
trigger some of them but is it actually
true I I have no idea I mean Fuentes
I watched Fuentes two I think it was
either yesterday the day before and he's
like I heard from people who were
working with Milo and they have no
reason to lie tell me about this and
that and that and it's like couldn't be
more yeah I don't like come on yeah give
me at least like a screenshot or
something yeah talk to me about
um being on stage when someone like Milo
really tries to sort of take the gloves
off it seems like you can keep your cool
which I think is a pretty impressive
thing to be able to do is that innate is
that something that you've developed do
you ever get asked for tips on debating
and what would you tell people
um I've always been like a really cool
person I don't know why
um the the my transition I worked a job
when I was uh 17 18 I worked at
McDonald's okay lovely fast food
restaurant and I was so good at handling
irate customers that somebody in line
there noticed and then recommending
maybe for another job at a casino that I
worked at where I also worked at
graveyard shift because I could handle a
lot of Ira customers so I've always been
good at just like dealing with people
that are just like this is dumb like
whatever
um so I I don't know why I've had that
skill baked into me for a long time now
when I run into people like that I have
to be very strategic like I have to
think a lot about how I'm supposed to
deal with it because my background in
Internet [__] talking is huge and that's
very very fun for me like if somebody
wants to roll around in the dirt I will
gladly like let's have like a two hour
screaming match I would love nothing
more but it doesn't really look good on
me so I have to be like very measurable
there are a lot of things I wanted to
say to Milo and I have to like pick my
spots very carefully
um why didn't you do that
uh two reasons so one in the 2016 era of
Politics the way that you communicated
strength to people was through like
destroying people like screaming at them
you know going hard like oh you're so
[__] stupid blah blah like that's how
we did it and that's whatever you know
that's why that was where my comeuppance
was was like being that really like loud
unruly angry kind of left-leaning person
that would destroy people
um but then 2020 onwards now the way you
communicate strength is this like quiet
stoic type of like manly like nothing
affects me so now when I'm like dealing
with people the way that you deliver the
insult has to be like it's got to be
like a bit more cool a bit more
collected a bit less emotionally
impacted so I kind of have to think when
I'm navigating conversations like I I
have to attack him because he's
obviously saying some wild [__] and it
would be really funny and have good
attacks but I can't attack him in a way
that makes it seem like I'm upset so
there's like a whole like strategy to
like dealing with people that are like
really trying to needle you you know
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]